this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armies Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from Quran history and on
today's episode we're taking a journey
down memory lane to check out some of
Jonathan's favorite weapons from 2022.
this is the the milcar M32 grenade
launcher this looks to be very well
modeled indeed including what looks to
be all the functionality that you would
expect oh that's superb to put put the
two two broom handles together insert
the clips and then smack them into each
other to load it that's borderline
genius is what that is Jonathan and the
whole team here at Gamespot just want to
say thank you for everyone who's watched
the show over the last year we really
appreciate your support and if you enjoy
this kind of content make sure to keep
an eye out for our new series Loadout a
show where we take a look at the history
and impact of some of the most iconic
weapons in gaming from the AK-47
flamethrower to the scar and stg-44
Jonathan will be making plenty of
appearances over on that show too so
make sure to check it out right let's
take a look at some of Jonathan's
highlights from the past year
foreign
[Applause]
it's my old friend the so-called broom
handle Mauser the c96
we have one here in its holster slash
butt stock that you've seen before this
is of the right sort of generation it
matched a really quite a close match for
the one on screen doesn't the hammer
isn't quite right for this model for
this commercial model of the c96 but
it's really very good otherwise all the
necessary Contours and cut out panels
and things are there I'd have to be
incredibly nitpicky to spot anything
wrong with that they've done a good job
thank you
oh that's superb yeah we often scratch
our heads at uh how how games fudge
reloads where usually for dual wielding
so usually off camera or kind of like
fudged to put put the two two broom
handles together insert the clips and
then smack them into each other to load
it that's borderline genius is what that
is and I'm not gonna do it but I
actually think it would work
ready three two one and send it
keep showing don't stop
wow that was that was seriously
impressive I saw the the model for this
uh big artillery piece and I thought I
was going to see one of those in action
and only to see a ton of them as a
coordinated artillery battery uh that's
gotta be the most impressive video game
artillery thing I've ever seen not that
artillery is really very front and
center in most games to do it any sort
of justice is is very difficult this is
probably the closest anyone's come I
would suggest artillery is still more
important than most other forms of
military unit and certainly most other
forms of gun so just to see that sort of
devastating artillery barrage like that
is really impressive clearly teams of
people having to be used to run these as
well which is which is realistic as well
in terms of the gun itself I think it's
Loosely based on the the famous German
Big Bertha Railway gun or very large
artillery piece which I did which did
come in a I think it was a 30 30.5
centimeter variant this is this is meant
to be 300 ml artillery piece big stuff
like this usually transported and fired
from rails because it's the only way to
get something that's what 42 tons I
think Big Bertha was it's the only way
to get these things around and into any
kind of position where they can fire but
when they do fire you're talking
potentially 10 well tens of miles of
range from from a big artillery piece
well beyond what a normal game map can
possibly handle so all very impressive
thank you
[Music]
the stair m95 infantry rifle I am
looking here at a sort of overhead pass
on this beautifully modeled virtual m95
very impressed with it ours is actually
in better condition than the one in the
game I'm not gonna say that's a
criticism at all because it's amazing
how quickly infantry weapons can can
look old depending it's more about the
the service they've seen where they've
seen it in what sort of usage and it's
incredible how they can quickly look
like military surplus in actual use but
it really does look good
foreign
as well I like the slight fisheye effect
of the Optics I wonder if that's
strictly accurate all of all of the late
19th century Optics I've looked through
have been pretty pretty optically
correct maybe the scope that they used
for reference had that of that effect
maybe they all do in this case I don't
know but typically by the late 19th
century you know the Victoria's new
Optics they could grind flat Optics just
as well just with more time and cost
pretty much as we do today so don't know
if that Distortion is actually Fair as
it were I did notice that the player is
finger and thumbing the bolt which is
easily doable when the cocking piece is
back when they're gonna cough it's a
little awkward to do in the way depicted
they're not impossible by any means when
you've got the spring pressure to
overcome I would expect more of a grip
like this so using the meat of the hand
finger and thumb but that support of the
hand and much easier and more repeatable
especially when you've got cartridges in
in the weapon that are going to induce
extra friction extra drag the most
important thing for me if I was advising
on something like this is find some
manuals and try to try to replicate that
because even if people deviated in
actual combat at least you've got a
frame of reference and and you can say
to anyone that criticizes is where we
got the sauce
foreign
I have not played it's gone very fantasy
I think it's fair to say well more than
sci-fi it has um well almost a Gears of
War Vibe with the twin blades under the
on the forehand there much bulkier still
has the the extra raised rib on the top
of the top of the breach which is a
feature of the original gun as well very
convoluted design we've got some very
deeply etched I guess it would be if it
was real decoration much more angular
looking the the the wood is sort of
merged into the design in a way that the
original isn't and a real sort of
shotgun wouldn't be uh but we do have we
do have sort of runes and symbols down
the sides I'm guessing this is a in
context this is a legendary ancient
weapon of some sort that we come across
like the original Super shotgun or
something
foreign
forgotten the the um gameplay that I'd
seen from this from when it launched
that the blades under the barrel are not
in fact some sort of gears-esque
bayonets they are in fact your hook
shots so that's a very interesting way
to make a gun that's been done to death
something special and different yeah I
can't comment on the use of grappling
under Barrel grapple grapnel guns
they're not really a thing grapnel guns
are though they have been made and
they've been made to work but I don't
think anyone's using them in the way
that we see in the movies and this is
they're certainly not using them to
skewer things where they pull themselves
into them in the way that we see here
but it's extremely cool and it leverages
the devastating double barrel effect of
the super shotgun in a very creative way
down
for now
all right this is really cool I I like
this quite a bit now this is what we
would call a combination weapon but it
actually is reminiscent of a real world
sort of gun I'll explain in a moment so
what it really is is a sledgehammer of
whatever poundage I'm not sure it has
the action of a sledgehammer but when
you do your alt fire I imagine it's got
a gun built into it so it's got a it's
even got a magazine feeding up into the
head of the side hammer and you can see
this the firing pin or striker and the
spring on the back of the head and then
it'll have a muzzle on the front of the
of the hammer and so it fires when you
strike and then you've got uh quite a
fun pump action to reload it now I can't
begin to imagine how that pump action
would ever really work I suspect the
answer is it wouldn't but it's really
cool and the real world relevance here
is it's very similar in principle to a
type of Humane killer the slaughtering
cattle or euthanasium euthanizing cattle
it's a long wooden
puffed with a head on it it's not really
a hammer it's not designed for that
impact strike uh because the idea is
when it contacts the animal's head
it fires essentially a bolt gun so it's
a bolt gun on the end of a stick but it
works very much like this I don't know
if the developers saw that type of
killing tool I suppose you'd call it or
if they came up with this completely
independently which I suspect is is the
truth but um fascinating for us here at
the Royal armories because we deal with
all sorts of weapons and armor and this
is a really interesting fictional weapon
foreign
[Applause]
this is the result of rebellion coming
back to us after our work on Cyber Elite
Four and asking and at the time they
were thinking DLC what have you got
that's really wacky but just about
plausible that's that's the secret isn't
it with a game like this could could
this thing have existed in that theater
at that time and be in his hands and so
I could not resist
including this in my uh short list of
suggestions and although the DLC didn't
transpire the SRAM is now in Sniper
Elite 5. first ever appearance for this
very unusual rifle now it says in the
description text it says develop the
special ops by British soe this is
actually not an soe design and it was
designed by them I think these guys
deserve some credit although I don't
have a single name designer for this
unfortunately but it was developed by
the check section and this is what they
came up with so it wasn't for Special
Operations type work it was a conceptual
alternative to the self-loading rifle if
that makes any sense to you and it
probably doesn't because looking back
it's a bit quick but this whole pump
cocking Arrangement where you press the
trigger that's not to trigger and you
pull back the the pump grip the the
pistol grip like it's a shotgun pump and
it pulls the bolt down a ramp
explain that in a moment and then you
push forward to chamber around that was
all about trying not to disturb your
your position and hold as a sniper as an
alternative to semi-automatic fire now
to us today that sounds a bit Bonkers
but at the time not you know not
everyone was sure that something like an
M1 Garen was the way to go they
commissioned in 1944
um 20 prototypes only two were ever made
we've got this one I'm guessing Carl has
left the other one in northern France
somewhere so ours is not complete it's
missing the front scope ring for reasons
unknown uh we've got some difference
here
um the rifle seems to have the very fore
end of a number four so it's not a
perfect replica of our only surviving
srem they have taken the liberty of
making the front end basically that of
the number four bigger site protectors
uh wooden wooden for end all the way to
that point there and then the barrels
sort of floated within the woodwork like
a number four uh that must be a
deliberate deliberate design Choice
maybe in this universe they have taken
this concept a little bit further well
he must have done it's out in the field
and they've gone with with that to
protect the the barrel I'm not sure
whatever the details uh it's really nice
to see this gun in the game and go I
hope that
sacrifice
whoa this thing is a bit left field
there are those conventional rounds
again jump lots of fan of in Far Far
Future sci-fi I'm sorry belted linked
rounds this is a belt fed gun I'm not
seeing how those rounds get diverted
into what is apparently an upper and a
lower Barrel the barrels have very
chunky heat shields on them that bring
to mind a number of designs I suppose
the the Browning M2 is the the one
that's going to link leap to mind
especially as I this is called heavy
I've got no sense of scale but I think
given the rounds they're probably going
to be 50 cal or equivalent but they look
a lot like 50 BMG although from a
profile view you can only see the one
belt and I'm thinking yeah they fudged
it they're just diverting rounds up and
sun down no this is actually actually
reminiscent of a couple of our
anti-aircraft mounts that we have in the
collection here at the Royal armories
where you have well what I'm thinking of
is four guns and you have shoots feed
shoots running from belt boxes is side
by side at different heights into the
different guns basically exactly like
this because this is two guns that
happen to be screwed together by the
look of it operated off one trigger of
course they're offset they're displaced
for and aft but that makes sense because
the feed region of the gun has to align
with the belt so to actually offset the
top one to the rear does actually make
some sense so what looks looked like a
pretty wacky silly design actually for
somebody who has a tremendous amount of
strength is starting to make some sense
which is funny
foreign
fire modes here are pretty intriguing
actually it's akin to deploying a bipod
in a more realistic FPS so we're getting
a reduced dispersion when we flip out
the handle and Brace the thing more
deliberately and which which is logical
I have noticed uh something that
detracts somewhat from the realism as if
we care about the realism but the
cocking handle on the top yeah okay
that's that's accessible um for the gun
on the top how are we cocking the gun on
the bottom I imagine it's a case of
there's a the cocking handle would go
straight through the bolt of the Top Gun
and be physically attached to the bolt
of the bottom gun in a different
location and sheer brute strength means
you can cop them both from One charging
handle that's what I'm going with
strong won't you kill something
so many wow interesting design very
Fallout appropriate there's very little
I can't see anything that is an existing
firearm part this looks like something
that's been invented from scratch which
is nice this isn't Star Wars so it's
stuff that stuff that's meant to have
existed in the timeline that isn't from
our universe shouldn't really
incorporate recognizable firearm
assemblies but I like this it's got a
it's got a sort of ray gun aesthetic but
also there's a heat shield in there
there's a conventional iron sight and a
gas piston arrangement I like the look
of this let's see how it plays
foreign
lives up to the name this says it's a
gyrojet system this being the original
gyrojet or the pistol anyway there is a
carbine version with a basically the
same thing with a long barrel and a butt
stock assembly on it so this is a 1960s
concept for a very sort of cheap
lightweight rocket gun so very simple
design with a forward Hammer that drops
to the rear strikes the the round on the
nose to initiate the rocket motor inside
and then the rocket accelerates back
over the hammer to recock it and out the
barrel so this this is like a concept
for what would happen if this hadn't
been an abject failure and had been
developed into not only a successful
pistol but presumably a rifle and what
they're calling here a heavy machine gun
now looking at the caliber of the
ammunition they're depicting here that
seems fair that is at least a 50 caliber
diameter projectile the rounds are not
conventional cased rounds as they
shouldn't be they should be their own
self-contained propellant with vents in
the back the only thing that's not
really clear from this is how it feeds
from the magazine because that little
mini Rocket thing is Thoroughly embedded
in that mag and I can't see how it would
line up with the feedway to then be
initiated by the striker or
what's inside
[Music]
right so it isn't just a Cosmetic Skin
for the ammunition these are actually
modeled as miniature rockets with fold
out fins such as we do see on larger
Rockets the gyrojet ammo didn't have
folding fins it relied on rotational
stability from the vents at the back
this looks like some of the single-use
rocket or well guided missile systems
have that style of folding fin that fold
out to give you that stability and we
can actually see the rocket exhaust on
this thing as well and as they travel
through the air we see a smoke Trail
which we would see and do see if you
watch footage of the gyrojet being shot
you'll see the little tiny Rockets
trailing the trail
foreign
M32 grenade launcher 40 millimeter gray
launcher it's not I suppose super widely
encountered but there are quite a few
out there as a grenade launcher it does
fire in quite quite the arc but that's
that's positive Advantage when you're
trying to lobb in explosives you you
don't necessarily want to fire strength
level anyway this looks to be very well
modeled indeed including what looks to
be all the functionality that you would
expect in other words being able to open
it up rotate the drum to different
position even selectively load different
types of ammunition into your drum
having having never fired one but having
seen some footage the it looks looks to
be realistically modeled the grenade
launches in games vary pretty wildly in
how closely they model the actual Arc of
a 40180 grenade this looks to be right
the size of the explosion looks to be
right yeah I I would expect no less to
be honest
oh
I suppose that isn't wildly different
from the hilarious Noob Tube of Call of
Duty close range use of grenade launcher
thing where
correctly uh the the round doesn't arm
at that short distance
arms through rotation it's a safety
thing you don't want the thing going off
near you the question is I think I've
seen somebody try to replicate this with
like a jealous and torso or something is
what what would be the damage to the
human body at that close range from this
low velocity but relatively heavy
projectile I'm not going to say whether
this is right or wrong except to say
that I think of it impacted in the
backpack like that you might not just go
down dead immediately I'm already
speculating too much it is essentially a
blunt trauma weapon inside the arming
distance
foreign
amusing dropping of four grenade rounds
there and the way they sort of gently
roll off into the distance for some
reason this has tickled me quite a bit I
assume you can pick them back up again
you definitely want to dust them off if
you do that now in reality there'd be a
small risk there of damaging something
by dropping them that would negatively
affect their performance not advisable
to reuse dropped rounds of any kind
really unless you're really in a pinch
or in this case you don't want to waste
some quite expensive ammunition
it's a really interesting gameplay there
with impact on a hard surface from the
grenade and the person nearby is taken
out more so than I think would be the
case in your typical shooter that seems
to work on a blast radius thing this
appears to be modeling fragmentation if
you're within like a meter or two meters
of that explode at the edge of that the
visible edge of that fireball
effectively you've still got some sharp
bits of metal cutting through you and
that's modeled so you can take you can
clearly take advantage of that in the
game by deliberately aiming at a hard
surface to get that
um explosion that fragmentation and take
somebody out selected mode Stone Cold
killer happy slaughtering
of what's that wow I don't know what to
say about that I kind of like it it
seems like something you'd get in a
fifth element sequel yeah across with
um something like uh Mr DNA from
Jurassic Park which is based on Old you
know 40s 50s training films and public
information films with animated
characters in them of course it's a
talking bullet that wears Shades uh
apart from Skippy himself the gun looks
kind of understandably normal it's sort
of a low profile self-loading pistol I
assume it uses conventional ish
ammunition but it's got some kind of
smart targeting capability that I
imagine I'm about to see the results of
[Music]
error premature discharge I'm sorry this
never happens
of course right I should learn to watch
the whole thing before commenting
because this is not at all conventional
it doesn't have a slide doesn't have a
bolt doesn't seem to reject any
cartridge cases so I'm guessing it's
caseless and has some tiny microscopic
internal bolt it also produces its own
negligent discharges as a sort of meta
plot point which is I think is genius
okay I've just noticed that there's
something reciprocating at the front of
the gun I'm trying to remain
professional and focused here despite
the uh Amusement Factor so there is
there's something cycling here there's
something chambering locking firing uh
God knows how and a load of other AI
electronic gubbins possibly final
footnote on this one is that we appear
to have ambidextrous slide release
controls on this only there isn't a
slide and they don't appear to do
anything I think they were probably
modeled as pinch to release catches for
the magazine which is quite reminiscent
of the P90 in the way that it comes in
from the rear and is Horizon contour and
presumably well this feeds from the
front rather than P90 mag which feeds
from the rear but probably the
inspiration for this but yeah those
controls don't seem to do anything the
magazine secures itself and is just
pulled off the gun
when it's empty but far be it for me to
criticize Skippy
right I think I understand the
autonomous aiming thing now so the gun
isn't aiming at all it's the projectiles
that are being guided so like like at
least one of the other guns in the game
you fire them conventionally or the
gunfires itself in this case when the
moon takes it and then the projectiles
are guided to the part to the Target or
in this case the part of the target
specifically that the AI is able to
Target really fascinating concept even
if it was done done seriously but
instead we have the sort of Borderlands
level humor uh which I
I cannot help laughing at the the fun
facts especially are uh are really
well fun
thanks again for watching if you enjoyed
this kind of content please make sure to
like this video And subscribe to the
channel as we'll have new episodes of
firearms expert reacts every Saturday
and new episodes of Loadout every Sunday
again please check out the links in the
description of the video if you want to
help support the Royal armories and
we'll catch you next time
outside
[Music]
foreign
[Music]